now you've probably heard this that
traditionally parties and power lose
seats in the midterm elections according
to the latest Quinnipiac poll there are
some troubling signs for Republicans but
all is not lost but check this out so
important you understand what's at stake
among independents a group that Trump
won by four points in 2016
Republicans face a 17 point deficit as
of now versus the Democrats among white
women a group Trump won by nine points
in 2016
they are now preferring Democratic
candidates by a 14 point margin and
among voters 65 and older they prefer
Dems by a 14 point margin now look there
there's no doubt that the left is
energized and they're craving for power
but if the Democratic party gains
majorities in either house of Congress
what are they gonna do well they'll try
to reverse all of Trump's progress and
crop progress and destroy one incredible
economic recovery industries will be
decimated jobs will be lost of course
the other obvious danger should the
Democrats win a house majority well what
will that be
well that sounds a little bit like this
I rise today mr. speaker to call for the
impeachment of the President of the
United States of America I would support
impeachment I think that you know we
have the grounds to do it
[Applause]
someone tell her that doesn't rhyme by
the way but do we want that rogues
gallery running the government
controlling federal spending its
stymieing the president at every turn
but let's remember should Nancy Pelosi
repossess that speaker's gavel you can
bet that she will Meyer the country in
endless investigations of the Trump
administration and plunge us into a
daily impeachment drama this no doubt
about it well tonight I have four
recommendations to keep all of this from
happening number one the Republicans
should be out day in and day out selling
the Trump economy go across your
districts and remind people that for his
administration its promises made
promises kept in the Republican Congress
helped them along the way
the president promised you peace and
prosperity and that's what he delivered
he promised to hold China accountable
make NATO countries pay their fair share
renegotiate NAFTA and that's what he's
doing
Republicans promised to cut taxes in
rollback onerous job-killing regulations
and they did that too
now this is why the Democrats keep
talking about other issues they're
talking about things like muller michael
cohen or stormy michael havin a tea why
do Democrats do that because they have
zero answers to Trump's success they
have no alternative except to go to
these tangential unimportant issues now
the president because he gets how to
tell a story he understands the value of
touting the economy as he did tonight in
Florida we're setting records like never
before since the election we have added
3.7 million new jobs we're in the
longest positive job growth streak in
history the African American
unemployment rate has reached the lowest
level in history
sorry about this women but the
unemployment rate has reached the lowest
level in only 65 years it'll be history
that was great and I think about a lot
of things I think about old flashback
sound but it really makes me smile given
everything that's happened on the
economic front to look back and what
Barack Obama said about Trump back in
2016 do any of you recall this when
somebody says like the person you just
mentioned who I'm not going to advertise
for that he's gonna bring all these jobs
back well how exactly are you gonna do
that he just says well I'm gonna I'm
gonna negotiate a better deal well ha
what how exactly are you going to
negotiate that what magic wand do you
have and usually the answer is he
doesn't have an answer okay well he's
got something I've it's a magic wand
maybe it's just great policies let's
face it
due to Trump's agenda we have record low
unemployment in the best job market in
decades and by the way we have three
hundred seventy-five thousand
manufacturing jobs that dip come back to
the United States President Obama
according to market watch today wage and
benefits are rising at the fastest pace
in a decade the employment Cost Index
rose 0.6% the second quarter a tick
below the market watch estimate of 0.7
percent more important the cost of
worker compensation in the form of pay
and benefits edged up 2.8 percent to
mark the biggest yearly gain since mid
2008 in other words workers are making
out better you bet the argument for
every Republican candidate go something
like this if you want to keep this
economy going if you want to keep this
job market thriving see your investment
accounts growing vote Republican number
two way to avoid impeachment and keep
the midterm elections and Republicans
Grips educate voters on what the demo
Kratts have become the Democrats let's
face it I've gone totally nuts
you know they now want to abolish ice
they believe people should not be able
to use things like normal gender
pronouns that's offensive to Democrats
they prefer that I guess we go to war
with Russia rather than supporting
Trump's diplomatic overtures to Russia
they want sanctuary cities from sea to
shining sea one guy even wrote a column
today a Democrat about how we should
have just no borders at all at least
they're honest now they have a world
view where illegal immigrants are
protected while our citizens become an
afterthought so on the campaign trail
emphasize how the Democrats are on the
margin they're the fringe they're the
radicals they threaten individual
liberty now this is the party now of
regulation and speech codes it's a party
that is intolerant of any view but their
own they want to turn our entire country
into like one big college campus where
every expression is controlled by them
number three argue that life under
Democrat congressional rule is merely
going to mean the nation will be locked
into two years of relitigate in the 2016
election in other words any real hope of
solving our immigration or spending our
entitlement or our infrastructure
problems poof it's all going to
evaporate with this economy roaring
right now we can actually focus on those
things because because of Trump and his
big victory we're finally out of the
post 9/11 crisis mentality remember it
wasn't so long ago that we were either
mired in the middle east or dealing with
fallout from the housing bubble the
financial crisis or essentially just
allowing China to dominate us with
impunity but thanks to trump we can now
as a nation have a real conversation and
a debate would be nice about the role
that the United States will play in a
world where the limits of globalization
have frankly become pretty obvious but
let's not forget the Democrats are
loathe to even be
considering that they don't want a
debate they want to personalize demonize
isolate Trump from his base the fourth
way to win in the midterms and in void
of Pietschmann be happy warriors have
fun in the campaign trail it is a great
time to be an American I can't think of
a better time frankly in my lifetime in
this economy then right now are you kids
out there watching these are the good
old days because of the efforts of
Republicans and this White House more
Americans will be able to pursue
happiness its life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness sometimes we forget
the latter part people can realize their
dreams
Trump was having that fun tonight and
telling those stories I was shaking
hands with policemen in New York City
and the first one came up to me and said
mr. president I want to thank you so
much I said what did I do
said my 401k is up 44% and my wife
thinks I'm for the first time a
financial genius she's giving him all
the credit she said
she said darling I love you so much and
he said yes I'm a great financial wizard
oh the audience was laughing and having
fun as a politics at its best is all
about making people's lives better
connecting with the electorate
personalizing the narrative and that's
what the president did tonight he's out
explaining why his policies are working
highlighting the results and the
benefits for particular regions of the
country I hope he goes to places by the
way that he lost in the general election
or where the vote was kind of close
don't be deterred by the by the
protesters of the resistance mentality
from traveling to places like California
Illinois Colorado and go back to
Wisconsin go to Michigan to win over
independent voters and even some of the
Democrats the president and the
Republicans have to take the wind out of
the resistant sails this is best done by
focusing on your results in offering
more solutions without the histrionics
or the side issues that will just be
used to caricature you later on and
finally if the president wants to do
something in Congress before the
midterms hey I would push for a
middle-class tax cut I know they're
considering another capital gains tax
cut but how about another middle-class
tax cut make what you already passed and
is working permanent and expand the cuts
you already have in place that puts the
Democrats totally on the defensive and
on the spot that means they're gonna
have to vote against their own
constituencies economic well-being
that's a great idea
it will run pre term strategy midterm
strategy there was something the
president said tonight about the wall
and his desire for the wall that caught
my attention we're going to have
tremendous border security that will
include the wall that will include the
wall we've started large portions of the
wall but we're going to need even the
way we negotiate we're gonna need more
we're gonna get more and we may have to
do some pretty drastic things but we're
gonna get it all right well I hope by
drastic things he's not referring to a
government shutdown
now I know a lot of you conservatives
are like yeah government shutdown and I
get it
it's tantalizing it's like the skeleton
crew is working the government and it
functions just fine for a time being and
it might actually force Congress to fund
the wall before the midterms although
I'm not sure that would actually happen
as a political strategy and I'm talking
about winning in November to prevent the
impeachment of this president I think
it's really risky it's really risky why
is it risky because with suburban women
with the independent voters that's not
really where they are results matter
making their lives better matter I'm
with the President on the wall a hundred
percent but if you're gonna take a risky
gamble on shutting down the government
the time to do that
that was last March when the hold
omnibus spending bill debate was going
on right that's what the president had
the good instinct it was in the morning
he voted on it the good instinct to veto
it well the Republicans made him change
his mind on that it didn't veto it but
that was the time to take the stand now
it's too close to the election the
midterm election in in+ you know I think
would also do it would convey a sense of
chaos and that's not what those
independent voters want to see they want
a happy warrior president they want the
economic successes touted they want to
know who the Democrats really are they
want it steady as she goes
so mr. president keep the focus on the
economy like it did tonight and your
party cannot lose remind voters that
without a GOP Congress you're booming
economy is sure to unravel and then when
it does unravel it's gonna give way to
daily impeachment warfare on Capitol
Hill and as for your Republicans who
still don't really fully embrace the
president's record I got to say this
frankly you don't deserve to win but for
the rest of you make these midterms just
the start of something phenomenal and
that's the angle